David: Wow.
David: and yeah, after we complete the analysis, the recordings are destroyed, and none of your comments will be attributed to you directly. And knowing that, are you again comfortable if I record the screen and audio.
Lauren Bolanos: Sure.
David: Great great.
David: So I've started recording and we can just jump into it.
David: So could you tell me a little bit more about your role at Va, and how often you're using Cms
David: upload.
Lauren Bolanos: Every day a public affairs specialist, and I'm on the lead on the web.
David: Okay? And for public affair. What? What kind of like content types are you typically creating on a daily.
Lauren Bolanos: So events, stories, news releases updating the health services and then the outdated content and the detail pages.
David: Okay, okay, great. And
David: let's talk about event images, because I think that's going to be one of our most relevant ones for today. Can you describe, like your typical workflow and working with an uploading, an image.
Lauren Bolanos: Sure. So for the events. I actually, because we are so busy and we have so many events, I actually don't include images. In my workflow. Because we post the flyers to our social media sites. We have Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, and Youtube.
Lauren Bolanos: We don't post
Lauren Bolanos: the flyers to Youtube, unless obviously, there's some sort of
Lauren Bolanos: special video promotion. But I because they're they are also posted to our sharepoint which is for internal audiences, obviously for there to share externally. So I just for a quicker workflow. Since we have so many events to post, we don't include photos.
David: Oh, okay. Gotcha
David: Then, maybe what about stories?
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, so we do post a lot of stories. It's a priority.
Lauren Bolanos: it was a priority from my supervisor.
Lauren Bolanos: and
Lauren Bolanos: we, we edit them down to the normal size. Honestly, I'm
Lauren Bolanos: it's hard enough to just get one image sometimes from people when we're doing this story? so I
Lauren Bolanos: I'm I'm okay with the one image.
David: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: but and then I edit it crop it for my coworkers, who are
Lauren Bolanos: I maybe need help getting it to the dimensions. But
David: And what what software do you use for that.
Lauren Bolanos: I use Photoshop.
David: Photoshop.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. Yeah. So I use Photoshop, and I crop it to the dimensions. If and I'll retouch it for them. I have a photography background, if it's like a little dark or something. But
Lauren Bolanos: yeah, yeah. And I haven't really had trouble, like, I make sure to crop wide enough, or shoot wide enough that we really haven't had an issue.
Lauren Bolanos: too much with like the dimensions.
Lauren Bolanos: and
Lauren Bolanos: I know, like talking to my team, and we also have concourse who submit stories which is
Lauren Bolanos: contracted communications for our master plan.
Lauren Bolanos: it can be hard just to even get one photo
Lauren Bolanos: for this story. Yeah, cause we do consent forms, we make sure everyone, you know, we. And then sometimes we're asking from photos from the people we interview. And so we're like, you know.
Lauren Bolanos: we're not necessarily getting. We're just.
Lauren Bolanos: We're not necessarily always taking them. Sometimes we're just asking for them.
Lauren Bolanos: And it can be a challenge.
David: Hold on!
Lauren Bolanos: Sure.
David: No! That makes so much sense. And I'm curious.
David: Do you ever use? Are you using the media library when you go through uploading? Or do you kind of just upload the image
David: new every time like a new image every time.
Lauren Bolanos: No, we upload a new image every time for each story.
David: Guy.
Lauren Bolanos: And
Lauren Bolanos: like, I said, if there's like a chat I can drop our
Lauren Bolanos: or link in the chat if you'd like
David: Yeah, so.
Lauren Bolanos: Balls.
David: The next part of what we're working on is I'm I'm I'd like for you to open your Cms. And kind of just share it with me. And we can kind of imagine that you're creating a story page. I'd love to just kind of see your workflow throughout like uploading an image. There.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay, let me.
Lauren Bolanos: Can you see my screen.
David: I can. Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay, let me log on
Lauren Bolanos: to
Lauren Bolanos: Cms.
David: Great, and I can like pause recording, or something.
Lauren Bolanos: No, no, you're fine, is it? Sharing? My the stories page.
David: I see stories. Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay? Good.
Lauren Bolanos: Then
Lauren Bolanos: here we go.
Lauren Bolanos: So yeah, when it comes to images. I mean, I'm
Lauren Bolanos: pretty happy. But I do know that like I have
Lauren Bolanos: had to just like
Lauren Bolanos: Let's see. Pump.
Lauren Bolanos: Well, let me pull up, you guys.
Lauren Bolanos: I see you.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: Sorry. I'm just trying to get back to the Zoom Meeting.
David: Oh, no, no! Take your time.
Lauren Bolanos: There we go. There. You are okay.
Lauren Bolanos: okay. So you can see that my screen with the drupal. Yep.
David: I can see that that's great.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay?
Lauren Bolanos: so yeah, I I guess, like, like, I said, like the feature that I would like is, you know how in stories you have this like nice caption.
David: Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Formatting. I noticed we don't have that in detail pages. So that's like, really my biggest feedback is that I've had to kind of
Lauren Bolanos: kind of make it up in Photoshop, but like it's not the easiest to get consistent fonts.
David: Oh, okay, so.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, so.
David: Like if I would.
David: Oh, go ahead. Yeah, please.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, let me show you example. So you can see like I did for our history.
Lauren Bolanos: like, I kind of had to. This is part of the image.
Lauren Bolanos: add in.
David: Ireland.
Lauren Bolanos: Caption because it didn't have an option to caption an image in a detail page.
David: What you're so what you did is you went in Photoshop, and you kind of put like a white bar there, and then you put in there.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah.
David: I see.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. So that's like, I said, this is
Lauren Bolanos: just, and it works. I got it to work, and it looks pretty consistent.
Lauren Bolanos: but
Lauren Bolanos: And then obviously, I would like it to be, even with whatever size image it is. This was.
David: Right.
Lauren Bolanos: Small image. Same with this one like it would be weird if the text went over here.
Lauren Bolanos: I.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. So that's that's really like my
Lauren Bolanos: I guess. And it's just. And like, I said, there's a workaround. So it's not like.
Lauren Bolanos: It's not
Lauren Bolanos: the worst thing.
David: Anyone.
Lauren Bolanos: But a shop.
David: I. I'm curious. How do you and I? It sounds like you have a photo background photography background. But like, kind of keep the consistency with those images as you're uploading them to width.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, it's been that was tough. But I I keep like all of them, open and copy and paste, basically. And then retype.
David: Okay, yeah, yeah, so yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: It I? And then I think, like I said, these might be smaller compared to I think the master plan ones.
Lauren Bolanos: like this is a little bit bigger, I believe, but it's on a different page. So this is like, not
Lauren Bolanos: I don't. This is a little bit less consistent.
Lauren Bolanos: That's for the
Lauren Bolanos: like, I said, this is for the master plan, so, like our concourse, people requested edits.
David: I see.
David: Okay, great. So now, the next part I'd love to kind of
David: see is if you could show me something like a story that you're like
David: we could like, start a new story, and then just kind of walk me through how you're doing that, unless there's a story that you already have open.
David: whatever is easiest for you.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, no, I can start a new one if you want
David: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: So here's a new one. V. Greater Los Angeles.
Lauren Bolanos: So it would be just the title.
Lauren Bolanos: It would be my name.
Lauren Bolanos: I listed here for a sentence. This would be like test is a sentence.
Lauren Bolanos: It's not spelled right.
Lauren Bolanos: So I'll just leave it at test.
David: They're there!
Lauren Bolanos: And then same thing here. We copy and paste it in, and then obviously, we have to double and check
David: Yeah. And then this is the bit I'm really interested in this whole image section. So yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, so we just
Lauren Bolanos: open it up.
Lauren Bolanos: And
Lauren Bolanos: so I have this photo that I've resized for my next story.
Lauren Bolanos: you guys gave us a nice large word, Count, which I'm very appreciative of.
Lauren Bolanos: I always end up like
Lauren Bolanos: oh, for the caption!
Lauren Bolanos: I always end up
Lauren Bolanos: needing more word count
Lauren Bolanos: for things.
David: So just a couple of things as we like before we keep going.
David: I so you copied that like long caption, were you?
David: Where were, where would you paste that normally.
Lauren Bolanos: So I normally paste that on the other
Lauren Bolanos: like. Sometimes I'll do it under alternative text. But there's a smaller one, so I'll just probably do like PC, MHI group photo
Lauren Bolanos: and then the caption is usually something same thing with this description. PC.
Lauren Bolanos: Image. I group photo, and then, after I upload it.
Lauren Bolanos: original.
Lauren Bolanos: and then reusable.
Lauren Bolanos: see an insert. Here's the caption, and then I just paste it in there, and you guys gave us a really nice long
Lauren Bolanos: oh, I appreciate the word, Count, thank you. And then.
David: So if we go back up, yeah, just kind of the to this image, uploading a couple of questions here. So
David: overall.
David: are there any parts of this process, or like the step through that.
David: seem difficult or confusing.
Lauren Bolanos: Not to me, I mean, but I
Lauren Bolanos: maybe my team no, even my team, as able to who my teammate, who isn't as tech savvy
Lauren Bolanos: post photos after I
Lauren Bolanos: train them. So.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah,
David: Do you ever get images that aren't
David: in the correct
David: format like ratio size or things like that? So you're having to edit them.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. So about usually just from my team, my coworker, who isn't as doesn't have the photography background that I do. I'll just he'll have me crop a photo
David: Conference, room.
Lauren Bolanos: But our concourse people know the dimensions, so they send it to us, ready to post without any need for cropping
Lauren Bolanos: And then I obviously crop my own, and then if
Lauren Bolanos: my team wants any help with cropping, then I'll do it for them.
David: Gotcha gotcha. Okay? And again. Another thing you mentioned. Well, you kind of went through it. Save an insert and save and select.
David: What's the difference between those 2.
Lauren Bolanos: I know saving
Lauren Bolanos: insert is the one
Lauren Bolanos: that you use. And then I just I cause I've I've used both, obviously, and one works, and one doesn't.
David: One works, one.
Lauren Bolanos: That.
David: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah.
David: Okay?
David: And
David: I guess. Yeah, overall. How is that
David: an experience for you of uploading that image.
Lauren Bolanos: It was easy.
David: Easy.
David: Okay.
David: great.
David: Then let's move along to our next part of this session. Which is
David: going. I'm going to go ahead and send you a prototype.
David: and I'll just get you the link here.
David: and I'm sharing it on zoom chat. So.
Lauren Bolanos: I'm not going to save this.
Lauren Bolanos: If we are, we done with this one.
David: We're done with this one. Yes, you don't need that.
Lauren Bolanos: Do you want me to stop sharing or to keep it open? If you know.
Lauren Bolanos: Anything else.
David: Yeah, if you could keep it open for the second part. That would be great, too.
David: And yep, I just sent the link
David: to zoom chat, so if you open it, it should just
Lauren Bolanos: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: Here's, oh.
Lauren Bolanos: okay.
David: Great thanks.
Lauren Bolanos: I see the create event.
David: Perfect
David: and then, if you could go to the left side and click proposed flow.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay.
David: And yeah. So this isn't exactly stories, but you can kind of see like the that module is pretty similar to how you'd see it on stories. I know you said you don't often upload images, but for this kind of
David: conversation begin.
David: go into that. So
David: I like to.
David: Have you imagined that you're start? You've started to create a new event for veterans. You've entered the date
David: which Va. Location it will be listed in already. So that's Bronx health. And now it's time to upload an image.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay.
David: Please show me how you would do that.
Lauren Bolanos: So do you want me to go back in here and do an event.
David: using the prototype.
Lauren Bolanos: The prototype. Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: so
Lauren Bolanos: let me just go
Lauren Bolanos: upload image.
David: Oh, yeah, there's only one.
Lauren Bolanos: and then
Lauren Bolanos: continue
Lauren Bolanos: and alternative, text.
Lauren Bolanos: yeah, save and upload.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, I mean, it's straightforward. The problem is like, I, we have like so many fires, and
Lauren Bolanos: Gla is very analog. And so everything's like 8 and a half by 11 for flyers.
Lauren Bolanos: Because everyone wants things printed. And we're trying to like push more digital stuff. But
Lauren Bolanos: because of my photography background. It's like a pet peeve of mine. I just don't like
Lauren Bolanos: things. Get auto cropped
Lauren Bolanos: if that makes sense, especially like an Instagram like. So we
Lauren Bolanos: we like.
Lauren Bolanos: I don't know. It's almost we. Just. We just put the information from the flyer just directly into the event description.
Lauren Bolanos: And then also there's the whole 5 0 8 compliance thing. So like, I know, like it's easier for screen readers to like, read the event description because they can't really
Lauren Bolanos: read a jpeg, unless, like.
Lauren Bolanos: it's just like
Lauren Bolanos: a short alternate text.
Lauren Bolanos: And then there's the whole 5 0 8 compliance.
Lauren Bolanos: if it's to attach a Pdf. Which I don't think there's even an option for that.
Lauren Bolanos: Not that. And I would don't want there to be, because then I would have to make those flyers that.
David: Again.
Lauren Bolanos: And we get so many a day. 5 0 8 compliant
Lauren Bolanos: And that would be a huge burden.
David: Yeah, kind of separating
David: this
David: from events
David: and kind of imagining the similar workflow for your story. Uploading image.
David: Does that change?
David: Anything like just like that process of uploading an image and and filling out the.
Lauren Bolanos: No, I mean, it's it's a form. It's just easy to do both whether it's an event or story. It's just a personal preference for us to speed up our workflow, not to include an image on the events.
David: 5.
Lauren Bolanos: And then also I could reformat things, or maybe crop things easily, but it might be harder for my coworkers to not crop through some words or something.
David: Got it, got it.
David: So a couple questions. So one is, do you know, if stories has a requirement
David: for like ratio size, ratio.
Lauren Bolanos: Yes, it's
Lauren Bolanos: this. It's like 5, 10 by
Lauren Bolanos: something. It's in our leaf system. Wait one second.
David: Oh, okay.
Lauren Bolanos: I can pull it up.
Lauren Bolanos: So when people submit, we have the dimensions.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, the stories are 1024, by 5, 12.
David: Okay, so that's like a 2 to one ratio.
David: okay? So yeah, I'm curious
David: when and I don't. Maybe we can go to the figma file and go to the current. Flow on the left, just to kind of
David: refresh on if you click, add media
David: here
David: select file and then pick an image.
David: So yeah, there's this crop image kind of accordion menu
David: that shows up for event images for stories.
David: What about like? So if we're doing a story right now, what would happen if you did? A 3 by 2
David: or a 7 by 2.
Lauren Bolanos: Honestly.
Lauren Bolanos: I don't know. I always choose the original at those dimensions. I guess that's how I was
Lauren Bolanos: trained. But for the person before me. I thought that, like those were the dimensions for stories.
Lauren Bolanos: So I'm not really sure what
Lauren Bolanos: I always pick original and make sure it's the dimensions those dimensions.
Lauren Bolanos: I haven't played around with any of this stuff.
David: Got it.
David: Okay?
David: And another question I have for you is one thing that is no longer in the proposed prototype is. Description has been taken out. Did you notice that.
Lauren Bolanos: For?
Lauren Bolanos: Not really.
Lauren Bolanos: So, just so, yeah, I
Lauren Bolanos: to me description, and like all text kind of
Lauren Bolanos: are like, I put the same thing in both most of the time. So and it is nice to have it like a.
Lauren Bolanos: So it in the is it just going to show the file name instead of the description.
David: Where? Where are you? Where? Where does it show the file? Name on.
Lauren Bolanos: So I know, like
Lauren Bolanos: we have, like under construction projects, a million things. I'm like scared to open this up for you guys. But
Lauren Bolanos: so like
Lauren Bolanos: embedded image.
Lauren Bolanos: So now the description is here. Is it just going to be like the file name instead.
David: What do you think it should be.
Lauren Bolanos: the file name is probably fine. I mean, I put the.
Lauren Bolanos: this is, okay. Okay, so this is the file name. Now.
Lauren Bolanos: that was, that's interesting.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay?
Lauren Bolanos: yeah. I mean, if the file name is like has a descriptive file name.
Lauren Bolanos: it's just the difference. If there's Dot Png or dot Jpeg at the end of the
Lauren Bolanos: so it
Lauren Bolanos: either way.
David: Other way. But having is, is having that
David: description or title
David: useful for you.
Lauren Bolanos: It can be. Yeah, actually, but I mean, if you have this file name, if you have a descriptive file name.
Lauren Bolanos: or if you have the file name like map one like versus like
Lauren Bolanos: construction, advisory sections of Vandergriff. Ave
Lauren Bolanos: It can be helpful just to like match the construction advisory with the map
Lauren Bolanos: when I'm removing outdated content.
David: I see. Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. But like I said, I copy and paste the title
Lauren Bolanos: of the advisory into the
Lauren Bolanos: name of the file.
Lauren Bolanos: So, and then I also do the same thing. I put it in the the description, and then I just delete the dot jpeg or dot png from the description. So either way, I make sure it's
Lauren Bolanos: this person's description. I don't know who did. This is not me.
Lauren Bolanos: If you are removing description, then I have to tell my team. Make sure you're the file. Name of the
Lauren Bolanos: image
Lauren Bolanos: is the same as the advisory title.
David: Do you so, just to
David: clarify? You will also, though.
David: take that
David: file or that like description, and put that as the alt text.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, if there's enough room.
David: Because one thing we are.
David: we are still requiring alt text always.
David: What if the Alt text throw it up there.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. So I like, I said, I copy and paste this
Lauren Bolanos: title into the title, the description and the alt text. Only I just remove the
Lauren Bolanos: file name@theendthe.png or dot jpeg, so I put it like everywhere I can, so it's easier to remove outdated content and like, know? Like, if I, you know, removed this one right here.
Lauren Bolanos: then it's the same. You know, it goes with this one, basically
Lauren Bolanos: so we have because of our master plan so much construction. It's insane. So this definitely needs to be updated. But to remove the old stuff. But
Lauren Bolanos: it can be a.
Lauren Bolanos: It can be a challenge to remove.
Lauren Bolanos: All the content. Some things have no images, some things have 2 images. And you want to make sure you're deleting
Lauren Bolanos: everything together.
Lauren Bolanos: the images with the advisory.
Lauren Bolanos: Otherwise it's just gonna
Lauren Bolanos: anyway.
Lauren Bolanos: this is probably specific. I don't know if other facilities do this. But this is specific to Gla that we have a lot of construction, and we have a construction page we constantly update. So people, we have an external facing
Lauren Bolanos: web page for veterans when they come on campus, and they can navigate easier.
David: Got it. Got it.
David: though.
David: Generally after going through the proposed prototype
David: and the normal one that you're normally going through.
David: Is there a preference? Are there things you like about one more than the other?
Lauren Bolanos: no, I mean, I can get the job done either way.
Lauren Bolanos: For the stories, for the events.
Lauren Bolanos: even for the description or lack of a description. There's more than one, you know.
David: Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Can make it work, anyway.
David: Make it work.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah.
David: And I'm curious.
David: are there any?
David: So maybe we can go to this question
David: ideally. You know, I want to make a an update to this. That makes your job easier. That makes your day to day as
David: seamless as I can cause. I you know it's that's the goal.
David: If you had a magic wand. Right? You waved it around, and you made the perfect image uploader for yourself
David: that works just like absolutely perfect.
David: What might it include? What features might that include?
Lauren Bolanos: So I'm gonna bring up our stories. Page. So that featured story,
Lauren Bolanos: is the dimensions so that you can get this nice like thumbnail. That's consistent. Is that why the dimensions are those dimensions.
David: I'm not sure.
David: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: Alright cause. I mean, I do like the fact that
Lauren Bolanos: these thumbnails are consistent.
Lauren Bolanos: and I do like the fact that
Lauren Bolanos: this is consistent as well among all of our stories.
Lauren Bolanos: So I guess
Lauren Bolanos: I I like how like consistent and clean it looks and like I said, I don't mind cropping like a story, cause that's like
Lauren Bolanos: 2 seconds, for, like a story that took like
Lauren Bolanos: 2 months to write or a month to write.
David: Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: So
Lauren Bolanos: I don't
Lauren Bolanos: need
Lauren Bolanos: more.
Lauren Bolanos: because we already have so much work.
Lauren Bolanos: If that makes sense.
Lauren Bolanos: I'm not looking for more
Lauren Bolanos: functionality. What we do is with our stories is we link to social media. So if we have more images or video what we do is on our social media sites. We link to our stories. So we use the image.
Lauren Bolanos: And then we have
Lauren Bolanos: like, this was a story. So this is. And this was a real. So we link to our stories
Lauren Bolanos: here. This was, oh, this one actually wasn't a story.
Lauren Bolanos: I do know. Yeah, I did a story for this one.
Lauren Bolanos: So and then we, we did a Youtube video as well. So we use
Lauren Bolanos: we do multimedia projects. But
Lauren Bolanos: we don't like.
Lauren Bolanos: if we need more photos, we'll put them in our social media. If we need a video to go with our story, we'll put them in our Youtube. I'm not looking for like everything to be
Lauren Bolanos: on the website.
David: Got it.
Lauren Bolanos: That makes sense.
David: Yeah, no, that makes complete sense.
David: And yeah, you mentioned, yeah, you don't want to add any functionality. You're there's already a whole lot to do? Are there things that.
Lauren Bolanos: There are.
David: That we can. Are there things like in like those flows that like?
David: If they were just like tweaked a little bit.
David: it would be faster for you. You could get.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. When?
David: But better.
Lauren Bolanos: When uploading an image. It would be nice if our healthcare system was saved, I guess, like so when you're adding an image. Here, let's do a story.
Lauren Bolanos: Scrolling
Lauren Bolanos: through.
David: Oh, I think I know what you're talking about.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah.
David: Was it.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, so like, when I'm adding an image here, it would be nice, if it kind of like.
Lauren Bolanos: if we had like a default or something, we could favor it. So we don't have to scroll to visit 22 gla every time. It would be like so like when we add an image?
Lauren Bolanos: it's this part. Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: I mean, it's like I said, I can scroll. But
Lauren Bolanos: that, that does take time. It would be nice.
David: Specific.
Lauren Bolanos: Was like saved, or if we had, like an option to save it.
David: Got it
David: anything else on this page.
Lauren Bolanos: Not really not really
Lauren Bolanos: but like I said, like I mean, I can scroll. It takes 2 seconds.
Lauren Bolanos: It's not a huge time sock
David: Yeah, no. I know.
Lauren Bolanos: But.
David: Anything else. I'm just so curious to see. Like what? Yeah, what what other things I can do to.
Lauren Bolanos: That's.
David: Really make this process
David: just feel a little bit more simple.
Lauren Bolanos: So, yeah, I guess this is, there's options
Lauren Bolanos: like I said, I usually make sure the photo is
Lauren Bolanos: ready to go before I include it.
Lauren Bolanos: So we I we always pick the original.
Lauren Bolanos: and then
Lauren Bolanos: is there. I I guess I really like this is kind of arbitrary where I do, reusable or not, I guess
Lauren Bolanos: best practices, for when you should check reusable is something.
Lauren Bolanos: I we really don't reuse like images, though that much so
Lauren Bolanos: That would be the only thing
Lauren Bolanos: I would say I don't know, and this isn't related to images, but word counts for the 1st lead of the story can be an issue, and then you can't link in here. That is not related to images. But that's my biggest pet peeve with stories.
David: Got it? Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Is that I. Sometimes people have really long 1st sentences, and then sometimes even in our national toolkits. They'll give us like a press, release.
Lauren Bolanos: or and like
Lauren Bolanos: they'll, they'll want like a link in the 1st sentence.
Lauren Bolanos: and then we can't do that.
David: Can't do that. Okay.
David: yeah, yeah.
David: I think you're kind of touching on my next question here.
David: Are there?
David: Is there anything else in like just the current drupal cms
David: that you'd like to
David: that you feel is missing, or that you
David: would like to be a little updated. This is more for like future stuff. But like we'd love to kind of like, know what you're thinking. There.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, definitely. So I run into this issue a lot. For the 1st sentence in the lead I run into like, not enough word, count and then and then sometimes somebody will like Link something in the 1st sentence, like
Lauren Bolanos: they'll want to link like like I did a story, for, like the wheelchair games, and then, like, they'll want to link to the National. And the 1st sentence, Webpage.
David: How do you typically handle those situations? Currently.
Lauren Bolanos: I link it in the body. Text.
David: Instead.
Lauren Bolanos: So I don't link the 1st mention. I link like the second, mention. I. It has been an issue in the profiles
Lauren Bolanos: for leadership specifically the staff profiles, so I can show you and then I'll just have to repeat the 1st sentence like a short version in the lead, and then a long one in the body text.
Lauren Bolanos: so like under about us for leadership, some people have like
Lauren Bolanos: this person
Lauren Bolanos: has a really long, like an enormous amount of
Lauren Bolanos: titles
Lauren Bolanos: and abbreviations.
Lauren Bolanos: So I wasn't able to include all of this in the lead.
Lauren Bolanos: So this is like a shortened lead. And then this is like a double lead.
Lauren Bolanos: so includes everything. So that is the word count issue. So I just duplicate it, which isn't like ideal. Obviously, to have, like Michael Simmons, was appointed twice.
David: Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: So that's 1 way I get around that and then the other way. I get around. So for news releases
Lauren Bolanos: like we got sent like a news release for LGBT that they forwarded us
Lauren Bolanos: and they wanted us to like Link something in this
Lauren Bolanos: and I just I just didn't do it.
Lauren Bolanos: And then.
Lauren Bolanos: yeah, so word counts and links in here are like.
Lauren Bolanos: I guess,
Lauren Bolanos: I guess things that cause it's weird like, I don't think the people who are writing are the ones posting like in the national toolkits.
Lauren Bolanos: So they don't know that.
Lauren Bolanos: Or if it's like from an outside source that they're forwarding us. So this was like a not from a va toolkit. This was like from
Lauren Bolanos: like the foundation.
Lauren Bolanos: the press release that our team sent to us.
Lauren Bolanos: And so they don't realize the constraints that we have.
David: Got it, got it? And is there anything else besides? Word? Count related things that you'd like to highlight.
Lauren Bolanos: Yes, this is another issue that I run into
Lauren Bolanos: So under programs, when I'm making a detail page.
Lauren Bolanos: I can only put a new detail page under the programs bar. I can't put it navigation wise like under health services. So like, for example, we had.
Lauren Bolanos: we have, like women's veteran care
Lauren Bolanos: has a detail page, and the URL is under health services.
Lauren Bolanos: And this is great. But, like other services, want
Lauren Bolanos: detail pages, and they're not necessarily like what I would categorize as a program.
Lauren Bolanos: For example, our rheumatology wanted like a gout care
Lauren Bolanos: page. Because they have, like a lot of websites that they've worked with and they wanted
Lauren Bolanos: to direct people to a Va website instead of a Ucla website.
Lauren Bolanos: So, and I don't feel like gout. Care is a program. It's just a disease, one of many that's under rheumatology, which is a health service.
Lauren Bolanos: So so unfortunately, because everything was grayed out under health services, I had no choice but to put it under programs.
David: Yeah, yeah, I'm I'm familiar with how it's built built right now. So yeah, I see that as.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah.
David: You can't. You can't put in a health service unless it's
David: like validated health service that has been like
David: approved.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, it's unless it was already created. Like the women's veteran care, LGBT. Caregivers and homeless veteran care. Those were like already created right. Those are already approved. But if I'm creating a new detail page
Lauren Bolanos: it has to go under programs, no matter what. And so this is starting to fill up very quickly, like it's starting to get a little
Lauren Bolanos: we're starting to get, you know, we're only gonna get more requests. So.
David: As time goes on.
Lauren Bolanos: and
Lauren Bolanos: like I said some of these like
Lauren Bolanos: like my healthy vet like, too, we have like a my healthy vet under health services
Lauren Bolanos: right like my healthy vet coordinator
Lauren Bolanos: like it would make more sense if it had
Lauren Bolanos: health services instead of program. And then like. So
Lauren Bolanos: this links to this
Lauren Bolanos: detail. Page
Lauren Bolanos: specific to gla.
Lauren Bolanos: my healthy vet,
Lauren Bolanos: so like it does it for some services, but doesn't do it for all services.
David: Gotcha gotcha.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. And that woman.
David: Curious. Have you reached out
David: to
David: the help desk for any adjustments within this.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah. So I've
Lauren Bolanos: asked to double check before I made the gout care page
Lauren Bolanos: to verify the navigation.
Lauren Bolanos: Before I created the page
Lauren Bolanos: and the help desk said that I should reach out to Vha digital media.
Lauren Bolanos: and then the Vha digital media. So I brought it up during office hours.
Lauren Bolanos: And
Lauren Bolanos: yeah, I I said that that's the only place I can put it.
David: Hold on!
Lauren Bolanos: Is this something we can change.
David: Gotcha.
Lauren Bolanos: And they. They said that that's the only place because I think, like some people were on the line, not just Vha digital media. I think some people from it, and they verified that the only option was under programs in the office hours. When I asked.
David: Gotcha gotcha. Okay?
David: Well, thank you so much for sharing all of this information where
David: listening and just don't. Yes, I appreciate all the work.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, I'm happy to help. Thank you guys for listening to feedback
Lauren Bolanos: and making the updates. I
Lauren Bolanos: I know it's not easy to
Lauren Bolanos: with so many cooks in the kitchen.
David: Lots of cooks for sure.
David: Now we have a couple of other questions. I do want to be aware of our time. Are are you okay?
Lauren Bolanos: Course.
David: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: Let me just double check and see.
Lauren Bolanos: Okay?
Lauren Bolanos: And
Lauren Bolanos: okay, nothing urgent.
David: Perfect.
David: So yeah, from Marissa. We have 2 questions, and Marissa feel free to also hop in. If you'd like to ask or like clarify anything. But I'll just read them aloud.
David: how much time do you typically spend? On pre work with images and photoshop on average, just kind of like from what you have.
Lauren Bolanos: Site, or just in general.
David: For, like
David: story pages or events, I think.
Marisa: Yes, yeah.
Marisa: for any kind of work. Yeah, just for any. Any postings you're doing.
Lauren Bolanos: Including like social media, or any of that.
Marisa: Well, mostly, for like what you're posting up on drupal. So when you mentioned adding captions? Yeah, like, on average, how many like, how long do you think that takes you?
Lauren Bolanos: not that long.
Lauren Bolanos: maybe like 5min to open up a previous
Lauren Bolanos: stories. Image. So I don't even have to like look up the dimensions. I just like open it up and then throw on another layer, and then I'm done and export it. So it's like
Lauren Bolanos: if I were to do it right now, like, say.
Lauren Bolanos: it would just be. Oh, you know what I think adobe like wants us to log in again, so I don't know if I'm actually gonna be able to
Lauren Bolanos: do it. But
Lauren Bolanos: I might have to log in.
Marisa: Oh, yeah, that's okay. It's okay. I just just trying to get an idea of your of the time you spend to get the images ready so that they're so you just click original on that cropping so.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, I mean, it takes 5min to open up a previous story image, and then I just copy and paste and make a new layer.
Lauren Bolanos: so the dimensions are right, and then I export it.
Marisa: Okay.
Lauren Bolanos: And take that long to crop.
Lauren Bolanos: Got it? Or I can always like open up a new file with the dimensions, and then just copy and paste it over.
Marisa: Okay.
David: And the images that you're receiving are there
David: major crops? Do you have to do, or major edits? Or is it typically you just paste it into your template that you've built.
Lauren Bolanos: Really.
Lauren Bolanos: sometimes, if I feel like damage like wasn't like.
Lauren Bolanos: This is a personal preference. Most of the time I get good images, but sometimes, if it's like a little dark, I'll put like a little curves on it, and then I'll be done. So it's just like
Lauren Bolanos: one more extra step that no time.
David: Got it. Got it.
Lauren Bolanos: And like, I said, we have our workflow set up so that people submit the images at the right size. For our stories, for the website. We really don't
Lauren Bolanos: unless it's a detail page.
Lauren Bolanos: Add that many images
Lauren Bolanos: like we did for the history. But
Lauren Bolanos: like, you can see for my healthy vet. We don't really have that many images.
Lauren Bolanos: We have images for construction. But
Lauren Bolanos: What is going on with this?
Lauren Bolanos: But we don't resize them. We just add them in.
Lauren Bolanos: I'm gonna have to
Lauren Bolanos: troubleshoot this page and see what
Lauren Bolanos: my coworker did.
David: One other question.
Lauren Bolanos: Oh, oh, I do have one
Lauren Bolanos: thing I forgot to mention.
David: There is.
Lauren Bolanos: So
Lauren Bolanos: I know.
Lauren Bolanos: there was like a
Lauren Bolanos: about us. There was like a Va police thing you guys did right here.
Lauren Bolanos: But I can't edit this.
Lauren Bolanos: and.
David: The police page, I believe, is like consistent on every.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, like our police
Lauren Bolanos: people wanted have a detail page, and we weren't able to like copy and paste.
Lauren Bolanos: The local information that they wanted. So now I have like 2 Va police pages.
David: No doubt.
Lauren Bolanos: and they like, I said.
Lauren Bolanos: Unfortunately.
Lauren Bolanos: like
Lauren Bolanos: they want information on who to report lost or stolen items to. They want our dispatch
Lauren Bolanos: they want who to send complaints to, and who to send vehicle registration to
Lauren Bolanos: and that's local information.
Lauren Bolanos: And then they wanted
Lauren Bolanos: this description.
Lauren Bolanos: So
Lauren Bolanos: I mean
Lauren Bolanos: nice.
Lauren Bolanos: So I guess there's 2.
Lauren Bolanos: There's 2 spots.
David: Uva police.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah.
Lauren Bolanos: Adam.
Lauren Bolanos: yeah. Cause none of this like has an option to input local information or.
David: Yeah, I, yeah, I don't think it does at the moment.
David: yeah, we'll we'll note that down as as something that is a concern.
David: Last question. Do you ever use media library for batch edits or
David: alt text or captions?
Lauren Bolanos: For batch processing I use lightroom.
David: Lightroom. Okay.
David: you're not using the media library to to batch process that. Yeah, you're only using your adobe.
Lauren Bolanos: For all text. I'm using drupal for the alt text function for the web page, and then common look for Pdfs.
Lauren Bolanos: And then what was the other one.
David: Captions. I'll text
David: image titles.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, for captions. Like I said, I would like the option for captioning underneath the image
Lauren Bolanos: on detail pages, because I think it looks really nice on the stories page
Lauren Bolanos: to have like that, Tiny. I it's very clean but like only if it aligns with the
Lauren Bolanos: image, because sometimes we have lower res smaller images.
Lauren Bolanos: And if it like
Lauren Bolanos: goes past the image.
Lauren Bolanos: it'll look strange.
Lauren Bolanos: Yes.
David: Has to. It has to be the full width of whatever and.
Lauren Bolanos: Yeah, it has to like, go with the width of the image. In case that we have a lower res smaller image.
David: Got it. Got it?
David: Okay? Well, that's all the questions I have. Do you have any questions for me?
Lauren Bolanos: No, no, thank you for doing this. I appreciate your help.
David: Yeah, we really appreciate you taking the time to speak and share your thoughts. Your feedback is really so helpful as we continue to work on the site and make sure it works as best as it can for veterans and for editors as well. So thank you again so much, and enjoy the rest of your day.
Lauren Bolanos: You, too, have a good one.